people like clusters earned I'm like
cool that seems [ __ ] slow and
egotistical its offense I think people
say no too often because they fear
ramifications
I don't think micro losses are scary and
empowering people to make decisions is
how you scale and to me I've always
thought that somebody doing in 86
instead of my hundred is better than not
doing it at all plus how am I ever gonna
learn if somebody is capable without
giving them a chance like eventually you
have to let your kid swim eventually you
have to let them swing the back and so
yeah I'm I'm I'm completely not driven
by fear and people are and the reason
people don't let people do things as
they fear it or they have I mean it's
ego a lot of people don't want their
understudies or their direct reports or
the people they manage to be better at
something than them it's just insecurity
I'm massively secure in myself and then
I
that's exactly right cable that's a good
insight you're doing a good job with
this and asking me these questions like
I say yes I give trust at first you can
lose it people like clusters earned I'm
like cool that seems [ __ ] slow and
egotistical like who the [ __ ] am I to
have it earned you know like great like
[ __ ] that to me Trust is given and then
you lose it if you're a [ __ ]
uncapable incapable excuse me and and
I've proven that you're not you're not
worthy of the challenge or the or the
role I think one thing I've noticed
though that is a counteract to my move
is that a lot of times when you
accelerate that too soon
people become entitled they get they in
the micro get a little bit of a high in
their supply and they think they're big
[ __ ] and they start having egos
underneath you when you weren't like
watching my people that I empower with
like I trust you blindly then not trust
people blindly underneath them is a is
heartbreaking happens often and is
something I'm thinking a lot about
you communicate around you distilled
that same methodology to the people on
to you so that there it's like a
prolonged process I don't I see what
people actually do naturally themselves
then try to micromanage it I think a lot
of people never get a true read on
somebody because they've over
manipulated their tasks and the person
is doing exactly what that boss wants
and to me to me ultimate scale is
allowing people to roam free and expose
themselves it's kind of like that rope
right I'll give you a rope and you can
go forever or you can hang yourself with
that rope I think that whatever that
analogy is that I've heard in culture
I'm sure as what I'm doing which is I'm
giving unbelievable amounts of rope and
some people will run into perpetuity
with it and create enormous amounts of
happiness and wealth and success and
whatever we do together and others will
you know get tripped up on it and get
caught up in their bungee cord and and
loose
[Music]